chaque week-end parmi les dizaines d'un
d'être qui officient lors des matches de
football à la réunion se trouvent
quelques arbitre féminin qui se sont
investis dans cette passion particulière
marie-claude banor par ailleurs
préparatrice en pharmacie revêt depuis
six ans maintenant sa tenue officielle
l'arbitre-assistant porte aujourd'hui un
regard d'une grande franchise sur un
milieu qu'elle a pour habitude de juger
drapeaux à la main comment vous vivez et
l'on vous d'être en bêta est validé bon
c'est vrai qu'au départ je n'ai pas trop
le football se trouvait ce type de
joueur que donner un bain
et après j'avais vu la coupe du monde en
1990 il ya des rues génératrice babel et
c'était de deux joueurs qui rataient
football plus amusantes ou rigolos et
c'est là que j'ai commencé à aimer je
voulais faire quelque chose en rapport
avec le football que vous vous rappelez
lui promets moi vous avez abstrait mais
c'est j'avais arbitrait avec un
téléphone qui fait la guerre et la d2
c'était à moins de treize c'était le
clip de la saint pierroise on sait plus
qui était son adversaire
c'était la catastrophe un peu ce que la
timidité ou plus la timidité que la non
reconnaissance de vannes
on s'est bien terminée
à ce moment là parce que les offres de
zen et bien que si on est très solidaire
il n'y a pas de problème quand par
exemple si on fait quelque chose de mal
l'arbitré c'est de nos bambins c'est pas
bien ressaisis toi il faut faire comme
ça il nous a beaucoup quoi est-ce que
vous vous sentez co2 par votre entourage
par votre famille il bat yam on a
harnik donc il n'y a pas de problème
mais elle même quand chez une dame des
critiques quand c'est mal bond à me dit
de faire attention
une dame des conseils via mon beau frère
également qu'ils avaient donc on se
partage un point et solidaires entre
nous il n'y a pas de problème il ya ma
mère qui me soutient mon père également
de même si au départ ils étaient contre
d'accord les coups contre il était
contre ils avaient peur de la réaction
des supporters lui s'il était là et
s'ils entendaient quelque chose de de
quelqu'un qui disait quelque chose de
mal ce mois il avait peur de se mettre
en colère mais maintenant ils approuvent
des blues arrivé l'année dernière parce
que vous avez possibilité d'être en
contact avec le joueur mais si on les
trouve sur notre chemin lady bonjour
mais on essaie d'éviter un peu et bon
dès qu'on arrive au stade on se prépare
la feuille de match il faut qu'on
s'occupe de la feuille de match qu'ont
fait un petit contrôle au niveau des
terrains et c'est après que tout quand
on échange et où là on demande aux deux
capitales de nous rejoindre et de faire
l'appel pouvoir l'identité des joueurs
mais sinon les vides avant le match
devant les joueurs et en quoi consiste
le contrôle c'est le cas on voit si bon
déjà si c'est bien tracé céline sont
bien tracé s'il n'y a pas d'autres ou
dans les filets pour les bus s'il ya les
drapeau de coin
ces trois habitent le terrain c'est
principalement des hommes parce que il
ya pas de problème devient une bonne
coopération vie noté une cette
différence quand même nous fait que vous
êtes une femme d'un diptyque j'invite
rejet jamais remarqué cette différence
c'est très bien accepté je pense que les
femmes invite sont très bien acceptée
vous avez le collège où l'on s'entend
très bien
le seul problème c'est pour se changer
et la douche après parce qu'on prend on
parie qu'on prend beaucoup de temps
on prend notre route après mais sinon au
niveau du football
l'arbitrage on est
tous égaux quand il n'ya pas de
différence et il accepte bien les fans
en tant qu un plus
par contre il faut une complicité dans
le trio arbitral fait d'ailleurs ça
commence déclare guy tu donnes c'est
l'avis de centrale donne ses cours cible
de il nous donne certaines de tâches à
faire tout d'abord leur jeu c'est
l'assistant qu'il prend ainsi que les
sorties de deux bus est sortie de touche
mais il ya d'autres consignes par
exemple au niveau des fautes dans notre
couloir qu'on peut signaler à l'arbitré
central également bon signe un type
doute sur une faute dans la surface de
réparation aussi c'est dans la surface
de réparation ou hors de la surface de
réparation
on essaie de faire un petit signal
arbitres mais ça dépend de larguer
trains et des consignes et de de données
par exemple la touche qu'on est toujours
d'accord un petit regard de façon à y
faire
on se regarde systématiquement quelle
que soit la décision qu'on prend pour
pour éviter la contradiction
vous êtes habituellement sur quelle
sorte de match alors là pour l'instant
je peux faire jusqu'à la d1 mais je ne
la fait pas je ne craque pour
mais je fais des plus jeunes moins de
treize jusqu'à la division 2 à la touche
est ce que ça nous arrive souvent de
partir hors de sa demie pour arbitrer
par exemple samedi dernier j'étais
intense années pour faire une
d2 ça nous arrive ou plus généralement
dans les hauts de saint-paul la division
3 une femme arbitre
ce n'est pas très courant est ce que
vous croyez que vous êtes apprécié et
accepté par le public s'était peut-être
moins puisque bon je pense que le
football c'est avant tout pour les
hommes il ya la surprise quand il voit
une femme arrivée on est très bien
sifflé mais quand on est sur le terrain
pour arbitrer on a on a droit aux mêmes
noms d'oiseaux que les sommes donc ça me
fait une erreur c'est on a la même on a
droit comme pour les hommes
donc ce n'est pas un obstacle pour vous
non ça va je supporte parce que je me
dis bon ben ça fait partie du football
il ya toujours eu quel que soit le pays
donc il ya toujours ces réactions mais
le plus dur c'est quand c'est une femme
qui le dit ou bien un enfant là ça fait
très mal parce que déjà pour l'enfant
c'est pas grave hein quoi est ce tout et
pour une femme je pense qu'on devrait
être solidaire et c'est pas le cas et
c'est ça qui me fait très mal mais de la
part d'un homme je dis mon bain bon ça
lui sort comme ça ça ne fait rien
quelles sont les qualités qu'on demande
à un arbitre déjà d'avoir une bonne
condition physique
pour bien faire la pratique mais aussi
au niveau de la théorie de bien
connaître des lois du jeu
c'est à dire bon bah par exemple moi en
tant que jeu
assistant de bien connaître la loire
nantes qui est leur jeu
à
de leur préférence pour une prépa compte
alors je dirais pas aux dons qu'on veut
je me fais trop petit riff mais bon bah
via de la pile de marseille donc c'est
peut-être pas que devant l'équipe de
france un bout de chemin
tous ceux qui ont affecté je vais
bientôt soin d'elle
souad heures carlos mozer est
actuellement un des deux cas j'ai du
talent le désavantage aussi se muer
faussement de saint-aignan 250 voix
basse et basse et l'entourage république
de saint aignan et quelquefois les
éducateurs qui foulent agissent mal en
s'énervant il énerve également le public
c'est le seul obstacle qu'ont pu se
rapportant à cette fin la vente est con
une troisième famille puisque vous les
arbitres quand on se réunissent et c'est
parce qu'on préfère qu'on s'entend très
bien dans ce fait des nouveaux amis et
on rencontre beaucoup de personnes le
joueur contaminé pour moi je n'ai bien
là nadal aujourd'hui de préval
rensing bas est passé quelque chose
comme on dit
on peut voyager également le contrat
ils sont séchées à la montée c'est en
france qu'on a fait les modèles trois
ans un panneau de la passion à ses
lecteurs au vigan comme beaubourg pour
moi encore plus vivant qu'est ce que je
monte un peu plus je fais la division 2
donc ça va disputer vite je vois notre
site bol pour que la d3 d4
au fur et à mesure ça la passion
s'agrandit est-ce que vous avez
l'opportunité de rencontrer d'autres
femmes arbitres à la réunion ou ailleurs
quand il ya des formations par exemple
entre jeunes arbitres moins de 23 ans
est un déterminant c'est vrai qu'on a
assez au moins trois fois dans l'année
on peut se rencontrer et aussi non lors
d'un match mais c'est rare puisque bon
il ya plusieurs habitent féminin aux
quatre coins de l'île et de quoi parlez
vous ben j'ai une très bonne amie dans
qui arbitrent donc on parle quelquefois
des matches qu'on fait mais plus
d'autres choses
dispo temps de passer
colas a le plus beau souvenir que j'ai
dans l'arbitrage c'est quand j'ai fait
le logo de syndicale des faits criant
prochaine fois brutal et devant des
milliers de personnes c'était super
on s'est beaucoup d'ambition dans le
monde
j'aimerais faire au moins une touche
encore de bi zoua et plus tard elle
traîne un garçon il a peut-être
j'arrêterai ont dû cravacher bas mot 4
et encore alors le message que j'ai
envie de passer du banc de football
c'est un sport par un fou on va se faire
plaisir
on
joueurs supporters et arbitre pas la
même passion la danse hip hop et
m me rend tout de côté ou
connaissait bien ce sport avec les
rebuts et ça passera bien pour que ce
soit les joueurs et supporters et les
actes